It can be hard to make
rational sense of the world.
But is your brain
your own worst enemy?
Here are four of the many ways
your brain's processing shortcuts
are playing tricks on you.
Welcome to cognitive bias.
Understanding a bit about it could
change the way you see the world.
So here goes.
A recent peer-reviewed scientific
study found caffeine consumption
is strongly linked
with developing cancer.
On this scale,
to what extent
do you agree or disagree
with the findings of this study?
Relax,
this study is fake.
However, your answer
will be directly influenced
by the amount of caffeine you drink.
Cognitive bias number one...
Self-serving bias is your brain's
strong natural tendency to interpret
information in such a way as
to unduly favour itself.
In this experiment,
caffeine drinkers rated the
study's validity consistently lower
than non-caffeine drinkers.
Subjects with a negative personal
stake in the outcome of research
were less convinced by the data.
How irrational.
Your brain will reject
perfectly viable information
simply because
it has negative implications
for your personal beliefs
and behaviours.
Likewise, it will tend
to eagerly accept information
with positive implications,
even if that information
is flawed or inconclusive.
So why does your brain do this?
Self-serving bias protects one's
fragile ego from threat and injury.
That last group presentation
you gave was either a success,
thanks to your brilliant work.
Or was a failure,
thanks to everyone else.
You gotta look after that ego.
OK, a new thought experiment.
Look at this parking.
What do you think
of the red car's driver?
If you thought poorly
of the driver's character,
you have performed
cognitive bias number two.
This is your brain's attempt
to explain behaviour
by placing undue emphasis on internal
characteristics of the person,
rather than external factors.
Consider that just moments ago,
these cars were parked in a way
that left the red car's driver
with little option.
Does that change your opinion?
Fundamental attribution error
is often performed when driving.
I'm speeding because I'm in a rush,
whereas, they're speeding because
they're an inconsiderate maniac.
Your brain has limited capacity
to interpret the world.
It can observe the badly parked car
and understand
that someone put it there,
but that's it.
To theorise about the historical
arrangement of the cars,
or the situational
needs of the driver
is a complex and
potentially unending use
of finite cognitive resources.
On to the next one.
Here's a famous experiment
by Peter Wason.
Play along at home.
Subjects were given
a three number sequence,
told that it follows a simple rule,
and asked to figure out the rule.
They were allowed to suggest
their own number sequences
and told to continue
until they were confident
that they had cracked the rule.
Were you thinking
of a sequence like this?
This follows the rule.
And another, something like this?
This also follows the rule.
So, what is the rule?
It's to multiply by two, right?
Well...no.
Your brain just performed
another cognitive bias,
The actual rules is any sequence
of numbers in ascending order.
So what went wrong?
Your brain landed on its first
hypothesis, multiply by two,
from there, every suggested
number sequence was used
to confirm that initial hypothesis
rather than actually test it.
A rational approach would be to
attempt to disprove this hypothesis
by suggesting other number
sequences that didn’t follow it.
But, your brain isn't rational.
It has a tendency to search for,
interpret, favour and recall
information that confirms
its pre-existing beliefs,
numbers or otherwise.
Confirmation bias
is based on limitations
in the brain's ability
to handle complex tasks,
and the shortcuts
that it uses as a result.
The brain finds it really difficult
to test alternative
hypotheses in parallel.
It's good, but it's not that good.
OK,
so you've learnt
a few cognitive biases,
you're now prepared to combat
them in your own brain.
After all, knowing
is half the battle, right?
Well, not exactly.
That's cognitive bias number four.
The action figure
and TV character, G.I. Joe,
famously said,
"Knowing is half the battle."
When it comes to cognitive bias,
he was well out.
Knowing is one thing,
but habits, situations and other
processes still rule the roost.
Self-awareness wont beat it.
You may know a badly parked car
does not make a bad person,
but you'll still feel negatively
towards them.
You may know your brain will take
shortcuts to confirm the hypotheses
it already holds,
but it will still take
those shortcuts.
You may know that your brain
will protect your ego at every turn,
but the ego security
will still be out in force.
So knowing about cognitive biases
is way less than half the battle.
Even knowing the G.I. Joe fallacy
about knowing about cognitive biases,
is still way less
than half the battle.
Funny how your brain can pontificate
about its own limitations
but do almost nothing about them.
But, in the true spirit
of cognitive bias
you will be able
to point it out in others.